joining us now Fox News legal analyst
Greg Jarrett New York Post reporter John
Levine let me that's interesting that
latest development that last question
but he outlined 17 million and we're not
even talking about Russia or China here
no I mean a month ago I remember they
reported 10 million into 20 llc's now
we're up to 17 million and now and up to
35 and 40 from Russia yeah exactly so
the question is what was this money for
at the time this has to be repeated at
the time this money was coming in Hunter
Biden was an active crack addict and
alcoholic Who provided no services to
anyone there was no reason for him to
take this money in the only thing that
he had of value was access to his father
let's get your legal tank Greg Jarrett
well Americans I think should be fuming
at what came out today the
whistleblowers laid out compelling
evidence serious Crimes by Hunter Biden
culminating in a very important document
Exhibit 2 signed off by the U.S
attorney's Office in Delaware to charge
him with multiple felonies but it didn't
happen it vanished because David Weiss
by his own admission in a meeting
confessed that he was stopped by
Garland's doj and two other U.S
attorneys appointed by Joe Biden and the
whistleblowers watched as the political
interference unfolded the search
warrants they wanted were scuttled
Hunters lawyers tipped off investigators
stopped from asking questions about the
big guys involvement in a bribery scheme
they were forbidden from even looking at
the laptop and their plan to talk to
Hunter that was aborted and of course as
you saw the statute of limitations
allowed to lapse special counsel was
rejected and you know Sean roadblocks
were set up at every turn this is the
definition of corruption by our own
government a cover-up
yeah you know let me go over Jim Jordan
put it really well today John he said
three different positions talking about
the prosecutor wife in 33 days three
different positions as it relates to
they don't know where they're coming or
whether or not he could indict in
California and DC and these
whistleblowers have to me unimpeachable
credibility they are long time IRS guys
they worked on the hunter Biden probe
the one that just came forward today Mr
Ziegler was the lead investigator for
the IRS on Hunter Biden he is a Democrat
um he has he has a lot to lose by by
coming forward in the sense that who
knows what his personal and professional
process one more IRS whistleblowers that
we know of but many more may follow and
it's a crime to lie in a federal
whistleblower complaint so this is he
would face very serious consequences if
any of his testimony was untrue all
right 20 seconds last answer Greg
Jarrett will Joe Biden be tied to this
money because it seems more and more
every day like that's that's going to
happen
I think he will but he doesn't have to
be in order to have committed crimes it
is a a crime for a public official to
confer a benefit on a foreign entity in
exchange for money to himself or his
family he doesn't have to receive
anything to have committed a whole host
crime if you give Ukraine a billion
dollars if they fire a prosecutor so
your son can make money in in a field he
has no experience in I think that might
qualify it's a violation of the Foreign
Corrupt Practices Act it's a crime it's
a felony Greg Jarrett thank you John
great to see you man thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else